the redwood forest is a very special
place
it's the darkest forest on earth
the trees are so tall they create their
own shadows
and in those shadows there are a lot of
secrets
[Music]
my name is dave cutie i'm a docent here
at henry cowell redwood state park
i consider myself kind of a volunteer
naturalist and redwood researcher
before coming to henry cowell i was a
engineer in silicon valley but i just
love the redwoods
i've always been an outdoor kind of
person
i've been coming here for 40 years i
come so often now i i swear i could
almost tell when a single branch fell
these are the coastal redwood sequoia
sempervirens it is the tallest tree on
earth by species
their wood is
very very interesting it's red in color
it's very complex genetically and you
can have some that are not like all the
others
albino redwoods have been called ghosts
of the forest
we have found 13 albinos in this park
and not very many not when you consider
there's 2 million redwood trees out
there
i really know albinos i know where they
all are and
i continue to look for more
albino redwoods have a very very
soft nature they aren't as structurally
sound as a normal redwood
and we keep trying to understand why
they form here
when we first started looking at these
things we said okay they're genetically
different
but it could be contamination so we have
done some testing found that these guys
actually collect more nickel than these
guys
nickel would normally kill chlorophyll
but the albino redwood doesn't have any
chlorophyll so it doesn't hurt it at all
so where's the source of nickel well
we're on a railroad
some researchers think it is acting like
a liver filtering out the toxic
components protecting the rest of the
forest
[Music]
when i first started here i started
telling everybody where they were and
then i started finding pieces of albino
redwood on the ground
people would go and touch and fold and
break off pieces and i realized that i
couldn't do that i could not be open
with people because they were gonna go
in and destroy it so their location has
been kept secret
redwoods are treasure of the earth they
really are
and the more you study them the more you
realize how unique they are and how
adaptable they are
part of the fascination of the redwood
forest is its diversity
i am continuing to be fascinated by what
i see